so our next speaker has been
a repeat speaker multiple times both
here and at the meet up
and actually i first met her
at the conference
as soon as i met her i was like hey do
you want to speak one time she's like no
and then eventually she's become a
repeat speaker speaking so many times
it's really great having her here and
another thing i've said this about her
many times but we have a little biking
group here and
she's also in a bike lift but it's also
great because she's a bike mechanic
and last i heard she had 12 bikes
i'm trying to aspire to that i want to
get up to 12 one day i'll take me a long
time but everyone please give a big
warning for our first speaker of the
second day
kat um well i'll start by saying no one
actually needs 12 bikes so i'll admit
that
but it's great to be back i see some
familiar faces some new um
i so the title of my talk today
i actually won't go into r code which
might be a first work for me to but uh
it's more theoretical and kind of like
my own observations on
um building causal measurement
specifically in industry um and i had a
lot of trouble writing this talk because
i misspelled causal as casual
like so many times including originally
in my proposal to jared where i had to
like panic and be like where the
program's already printed because i
actually misspelled it as casual
not casual
um but thankfully i think we got it
right in time for the programs
um
so a little about me as sharon mentioned
i'm a repeat new york speaker i started
coming to this in 2016.
this was back when i worked for
a 20 000 person company um and it you
know we were fully embedded into teams
and i felt really siloed as a data
scientist and just wanted to meet other
people like me who worked on similar
problems or different problems but using
similar methods
um and
i've stepped in multiple times now as a
backup speaker so you're welcome jared
um and
yeah i love coming to these things i
think um i took a short break
i guess during the pandemic for my my
own
sanity
but it's great to be back and it's great
to see you all and
just catch up and socialize
so i also mentioned in my last slide
that i'm an our ladies member
our ladies is a really great group if
you're a woman in data science and want
to meet and network with other women who
also are passionate about our
um
and
just as an overview when i came in 2016
um you can kind of see through the years
how much we've grown um
from 2017
to 2018
um
to 2019 and we're a little overdue for
an in-person photo
but i'm sure the community is even
larger today
so i'm really grateful for that i think
something that the our community offers
is it's a really inclusive
community for learning how to program
for learning about data science and
groups like this also
just make it so much easier
um so a little more about me i'm a data
science manager currently at twitter um
i have experience at a few different
size companies so
um both online and offline
uh companies or companies i guess with
both an online and offline presence and
that's kind of important for this talk
so i'll go more into that next um and at
various stages so
both early stage uh twitter of course is
a little larger or
significantly larger
as well as i've also worked for an
airline a gym franchise
in which it's it's a lot harder to do
online experimentation um as well as
healthcare and elections where you might
be doing
field experiments and not necessarily
online controlled experiments
but my talk today is about building
causal measurement um and i'll actually
be focusing a little bit more on
i guess the use case of online control
experiments where you do have a platform
for running that
although hopefully
some of these findings or reflections
might be generalizable to offline
experiments as well
so
the inspiration for this talk something
that happens when you work for twitter
is you have a lot of conversations on
twitter sometimes with the people you
work with um so there's really great
meme
i don't know if you remember seeing this
but it's julia fox kind of saying you
know i don't know something like i don't
want to brag but like you know it's a
masterpiece or something like this and
one of the product managers who i work
with share this kind of um
saying making a
you know self-deprecating joke about p.m
sharing experiment results too early um
and i appended to it with some labels
you know of data science kind of being
that um she was wearing this crazy dress
with like a claw on her neck
of data science kind of stopping pm's
from sharing early results and
that's something that we find ourselves
doing often
but yeah all this is to say
experimentation is really core to what
data scientists do and um we have a
really robust experimentation platform
that allows us to run experiments at
scale at twitter
and actually at codecademy too we did a
fair amount of iterative experimentation
and a lot of our work is to guide people
like product managers or engineers and
how to interpret and set up experiments
um but the inspiration for this talk is
really on this reply from another
product manager i worked with that said
i don't know much but one thing i know
is if it's not in a causal hold back or
hold out um catherine is not impressed
by cute experiments
um and i guess the spoiler for this talk
is upon reflection experimentation is
complicated and i actually am impressed
so this is kind of me going into
just reflecting on what i've learned in
online controlled experiments
particularly with setting up holdouts
you know i'll go a little bit more into
what i mean when i say hold out versus
an experiment
um so part one of this talk is me kind
of reflecting on this statement
experiments alone aren't good enough
um so really that's what my co-worker
was suggesting right of you know when
you run just short-term experiments
that's not good enough
it's better to also have a holdout
so just as a quick primer why do we run
experiments
and i'll talk about two primary use
cases
and they're related but distinct so the
first one is you want to gather data to
help make a decision on whether or not
you ship something so typically a
company will ship or release a feature
if the impact from the experiment is
positive even if the confidence
intervals are quite wide so
um you know if it's even if the
the magnitude is anywhere between like
two to like
10 or something well
it's it's positive enough uh the second
use case is we want to estimate what the
impact would be if we rolled it out a
change to 100 of the population so
typically when you run an experiment
you're isolating a singular change
rolling it out as one experiment and
you're trying to estimate like what
would be the impact if i were to scale
this up to maybe hedge your bets reduce
your risk
and so on
um so
that's kind of an overview of a standard
experimentation approach where you test
isolated changes one at a time
with individual a b tests so the life
cycle looks something like like this you
build something new
you run an experiment
you analyze the results and you make a
decision and you ship it and you never
think about it again
and that's an approach that's commonly
used by
growth teams that
just are making a lot of small changes
they're testing them so this kind of
test and learn or growth team model
where they're using experiments to
decide what to ship
and when i say experiments we're
typically running these for one to two
weeks on a limited sample size you don't
want to exhaust or run out of people to
run experiments on
which
has some limitations so one of the first
ones is it doesn't allow us to
understand long-term effects
so novelty effects post launch that
typically happens people get excited you
launch something new they're trying it
out
they're using it a lot and maybe over
time that peter's out so if you run that
for one or two weeks you might not be
able to observe that effect
i say one week because that's that's
kind of the bare minimum of when you of
how long you typically want to run an
experiment just to observe the
seasonal effects throughout the week but
um that's that could be a whole separate
talk in terms of best practices for
experiments
um but anyway so going back to
to limitations uh the second uh
limitation
is uh it's actually pretty imprecise for
measuring impact if you want to know
what would happen if we roll this out to
100
so if you remember from the previous
slide um this was
the second use case for you know why we
wouldn't want to run experiments in the
first place
um so why is that so
um if any of you have ever run
experiments in practice online
even even at a place like twitter even
when you have a lot of traffic more
often than not your results are not
statistically significant um and that
can be really hard or really frustrating
for trying to decide what to do
especially if your if your goal
is to
figure out what the what things would
look like if you roll it out to 100 so
it might be okay for fulfilling that
first use case in terms of deciding
whether or not you ship something so
it's not negative it's positive
you know it's it's not risky enough to
to not ship it but it really doesn't
help you with this if your confidence
interval is quite wide
um
so you might say well why don't we just
sum up all the experiment results and
you can't actually do that to measure
your total combined impact so
um if you were to ask most businesses or
organizations they don't
they don't really care about you know
the impact of an individual change they
want to know like what was your
cumulative
impact of like everything that we did
you did or everything that you changed
um
and it's a statistical fallacy to
actually sum everything up because there
you know
there's a lack of independence with
experiments you're running often times
there's variance in the confidence
intervals
it's not quite as simple as just summing
up the midpoint
so what's the solution uh incremental
holdouts are
uh kind of core to what i'm talking
about today and this is kind of like the
gold standard of experiment of online
controlled experiments so
um a high level overview is every
quarter or every half and i'll kind of
talk through different cadences you may
run and why you hold out a group of
users
um from all of the features your team is
launching so you're bundling all the
changes you made throughout that time
frame and holding that back from a group
of users
um
and
at the end of the quarter or end of the
half you're comparing metrics from the
holdout group to all other users and you
kind of rinse and repeat you bucket a
new fresh group of users uh into a new
holdout group next quarter and you kind
of repeat the cycle in order to
enable regular measurement of the impact
that you're making every quarter or
every half or whatever desired cadence
and why do we do this it helps us
understand the total impact of
everything we launched last quarter
which
might be a goal that a lot of
organizations would strive for
and you know it's a little more rigorous
it allows you to observe long-term
effects particularly in lagging metrics
like retention um you might not see the
results on a short-term experiment this
retention takes a while to
materialize in user behavior
um and i i guess to go back into why
it's a gold standard uh
we're statisticians right we love more
validation and it really helps you
validate
your experiment results even further so
one it helps you determine whether a
positive experiment result was due
simply to novelty effects
and two it helps you
potentially identify confounding effects
from multiple features being shipped
so something might be positive but in
conjunction with something else
it might cannibalize or wash out those
effects
and i guess i'll also say throughout
this talk when i say experiments i'm
typically referring to
these short term one to two week
experiments um or or a b tests
or a multivariate test but the key is
short term
and measuring potentially one or very
few changes and when i say hold out or
hold back i might use those
interchangeably i'm referring to this so
a bunch of changes bundled together
and
being held out from a group of users um
and
i'll go into
to this next but something that we run
into often is is this kind of uh tension
of like do we put it in hold out or do
we just run just run an experiment
um so part two is you know part part one
you can kind of see um i guess just in
summarizing holdouts and experiments you
know all this sounds pretty compelling
if you're a statistician you're like
this sounds great right that sounds so
promising why wouldn't you do this
everyone should be doing this
so
so part two is implementing a holdout
and what that looks like in practice
so i actually won't go too deep into the
engineering platform or architecture
itself today um
so you know if you're considering
running a hold out all of this assumes
that you probably already have a pretty
robust experimentation tool for running
experiments at scale
and what does that look like so on a
high level a holdout is really just a
collection of feature switch
configurations running together
for a longer period of time
so the the systems are mechanisms for
withholding features or
whether you're running an experiment
that's short term or a holdout which
runs for longer and
it's it's really the same so um i have
this meme here where you know data
scientists
we think that functionally right a b
tests and holdouts are very different um
but if you were to ask the software
engineer
they would probably say it's the same
thing
to them right it's it's maybe more work
but it's it's the same same ask
um so here's here's what a sample
holdout schedule might look like so in
in practice here's um when you implement
it it looks something like this and this
is actually an example from hulu
i thought this was a cool public blog
from them about implementing holdouts at
who and disney streaming um i
credited down there so you can take a
look
but this is what it would look like if
you were to run this in a quarterly
period
here
is a different example where you might
run it by half or six month cadence
and i'll talk more about you know
when you might decide to run at various
cadences but
you have so here you have a holdback
that's running for or hold out that's
running for for 12 months um and there's
a warm-up period and during the warm-up
period
we're bucketing or we're enrolling users
into the holdout we're observing their
behavior but we're not reporting our
results yet um
or you know the results are baking some
pms we'll say um the reporting period is
when we're actually able to evaluate and
report on the results and you're kind of
cycling through this
um over time so
all right so uh i mentioned choosing an
appropriate time frame so really what
you want to decide is how long to run
your hold out for so you don't want it
to be
so long that it becomes too costly to
maintain um and and negative to user
experience so you don't want to be
holding holding out features
or putting users in a version of your
application from like two years ago
um but not so short that you can't
observe the long-term impact because
really that's what you're trying to do
um understand the long-term impact on
metrics
um so how does this work so each holdout
runs for 12 months it's split into two
halves the first six months is your
warm-up period and the second six months
is a reporting period um so at any given
time
each engineering or product team is
maintaining both holdouts in parallel
one in warm warm-up and one in reporting
um and you'll you'll run these for 12
months total and at the end of 12 months
it's important that you retire the hold
out and release users to the production
experience just to not keep them in this
really old version of whatever you're
used to run which might be slower or
be missing a lot of desirable features
or whatnot
so lesson certain so i kind of went over
a high level overview
if you've done this maybe you're like
this is hard this seems costly if you
haven't done this or you're new to this
it might seem a little simple
um but the biggest lesson that i learned
is actually uh and this is actually a
reference also in that hula article and
um actually by a lot of
there is this paper from an online
controlled experiment summit um
where they got a lot of different
companies together and one of the
biggest findings is
um you know a lot of the hard part is
not the data science it's it's the
engineering so
um
this option running a holdout usually
has a really um
expensive engineering cost so
your development team is maintaining a
code fork um that's not updated for a
really long time and that gets really
messy um so as a data scientist i'm i'm
not the person maintaining multiple code
paths um for a year old version of of
the app i'm not dealing with the the
tech debt i might see it tangentially
but i'm not directly doing it oftentimes
so i don't directly see or work on the
investment that goes into this by
development teams and that was something
that you hear a lot from engineering
teams
um
so
what do we do about this i think the
things that you need to build um are
again focusing on your experimentation
platform and making that better um so
some of the pain points and solutions
that we identified are number one it
sometimes takes a lot of time or effort
to implement experiments so you really
want to reduce the amount of time or
effort it takes
to
um actually setting that up um two you
want to make it easier uh i guess it's
hard to ever make it easy but you want
to make it easier to maintain multiple
code paths because again you need to
support both the old and new version of
the feature for a pretty long time
um and three you want some level of
automation so
something that you hear from from teams
doing this for the first time is there's
a lot of manual or repetitive work and
anytime you do that that can introduce
bugs or mistakes
and when you're adding these feature
switches and logic
constantly to multiple holdouts it can
cause a lot of
of issues that you might not anticipate
so you want some level of automation
there hopefully
and it takes a while to build that
pattern and behavior so you can figure
out what to automate
again that could be a whole other talk
so i won't go into too much into that
today but um
there's so many other things i could
have covered but i guess one other thing
is app latency can also become an issue
so if you're
a lot of the code is invisible but it's
still there so it can boggle down your
app it can still cause a negative user
experience and it's a lot of bloat
so lesson two
getting people to follow a new process
is really really challenging
so i say this about a lot of things but
a lot of problems are actually people
and process problems
and not you know not just technical
problems so as the saying goes it's like
hurting cats
i have a lot of cats
if you also have cats you know what i
mean by this
so when you have an organization that's
like thousands of people
it becomes infinitely harder to scale
knowledge and to get teams to follow a
new protocol
so how do we make this better so
not having organizational buy-in is a
non-starter so i have that as
the first thing you really need to do
so you want to understand as with most
data requests it's you know why are we
even doing this so it's expensive to
build this what are we using it for so
some organizations might evaluate teams
based on their collective performance
using these holdouts and that might
provide some incentive
from leadership or from top down to
actually
maintain this or to actually work on
this
some organizations make it really clear
that rigorous learning is a priority
and that you want to validate your
experiment results a little bit further
to make sure people are
you know choosing experiment results by
running a lot of things i mentioned
growth teams or growth hacking right if
you try to sum up your experiment
results you might be over exaggerating
what the impact is um
so but again your your
organization needs to make it clear that
you know they see the value in this and
make it clear to teams that they should
be working on this and and why
the second thing you need is
hopefully teams are a little more mature
and well oiled and already following
some shared set of principles or
processes so that
step three when you try to adopt a
feature launch protocol
with specific guidelines on how to
actually configure features until hold
out you want to make your engineering
requirements really clear
it doesn't feel so foreign right they
already have assured language your
protocols this is just another thing
similarly you want to maintain
documentation on what features are
included in the holdout
and you want to do this for context and
for visibility when someone's trying to
interpret what's going on
a holdout again if you remember is a
number of changes together at once so
if you're not documenting that it might
be hard to remember or interpret what's
going on there
and lastly you want to develop a shared
framework for analysis and reporting um
to make sure that you're all kind of
consistently looking at this the same
way
um lesson three um
i guess one of the things that i i
arrived at i was also you know maybe
maybe you don't need a hold out and i'll
put yeah because i think you know any
any company would benefit from it if you
can do it um but one of the lessons that
i learned is learning from a few
well-run experiments are significantly
more valuable than trying to analyze a
poorly maintained holdout so
also as a reminder even even a
well-maintained holdout right doesn't
give you a deep understanding
that you would gain from running
independent experiments because there's
you don't know which specific change is
positive or negative so i would argue
that you know experiments are are more
valuable than than holdouts um and of
course the gold standard is having both
in conjunction but if i were to choose
one um you know don't put the cart
before the horse focus on getting
experiments right first um
so here are some signs a team might not
be ready to implement a holdout um so i
mentioned in lesson one if you have
engineering bandwidth
maybe there are faster cheaper ways to
get to the measurement that you need
maybe you don't need to chase precision
and kind of go down this rabbit hole
which can be costly
and again garbage can garbage out you
know if
you're not maintaining the the integrity
or
quality of your hold out it's it's not
that useful
um a second sign might be your engineers
or your development team is
inexperienced with experiments to begin
with so
um
if they have a hard time running just a
standard a b test
you want to get them familiar with
running and maintaining shorter smaller
experiments to start and getting that
right before they they graduate to
running holdouts
and lastly
one thing that ties back to that
schedule is maybe your teams aren't
shipping fast enough or at a regular
enough cadence so again developing those
patterns to require a hold out so um
if you're you're not doing that then
then you know you're probably better off
running um experiments as needed or
until you develop some sort of
regularity um same can be said for
impacting the same set of metrics
consistently um if all of your
experiments are impacting different
metrics if you roll them all into a
holdout you're probably not going to
see much value from that
so i talked about all these lessons
learned but would i do it again yes
it's great when it works so i think for
more mature teams who have all
ingredients to actually implement and
maintain a holdout um
it does what it promises so
um you you know in this new cycle you
run a standard experiment for two for
one or two weeks as you previously would
um
then you would uh if it's positive
launch the tree launch it to all users
but withhold the change from the holdout
and as promised it gives you more time
to observe the impact on lagging metrics
like retention
you ideally get past that novelty window
or novelty effect
that you see with shorter term
experiments and understand the true
impact
and it provides additional validation
to help you
actually understand compounding or
interaction effects from multiple
launches
and again this this diagram from a blog
post which is is pretty good for for
looking at another example at hulu and
disney
um so i guess to return back to to the
original
thesis or impetus for this talk
or interaction i had with my team
you know while holy having a hold out
might be the gold standard of of online
experimentation they're not always
necessary they're not always possible um
when you're trying to build causal
measurement and actually i i am pretty
impressed by some teams that run
experiments because experimentation as a
whole is really hard and just because
you have this tool or method
at your disposal it doesn't mean you
should always use it
so here are some additional resources i
i reference a few of these um
ronnie kojavi has a lot of really good
literature on practical considerations
for online controlled experiments
i cite this book quite a lot
trustworthy online controlled
experiments
is probably the best resource i've seen
for industry examples
i mentioned this blog post from from who
and sean taylor's talk
he gave one
pretty recently about experimentation
and causal measurement um that was
pretty useful as well
and
yeah that's that's all for me i hope
this was useful and
i'm a little over time but thank you and
see you all soon
all right thank you